hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how biomarker testing
shapes immunotherapy presented by dr.
Conde Carmack vice-president of
precision oncology gsella Diagnostics we
are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
gsella Diagnostics for more information
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green June 8 button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button on the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Conde Carmack I will
now turn the presentation over to him
well great
surely after a long research and
developed development phase anti-cancer
immunotherapies have burst onto the
oncology scene and are producing some
remarkable results and they promise to
get even better lesson 10 years ago the
field consisted of true believers
immunologists who were convinced that
the immune system could be taught
tricked cajoled bribed lured seduced and
to mounting an immune response against
tumors there were a handful of anecdotal
cases that kept the believers going just
enough to keep the funding and the
passion alive things dramatically change
with rapid developments in terms of
scientific understandings and clinical
outcome the identification of cancer
specific antigens recognized by immune
cells and the elucidation of inhibitory
pathways that lead to cross talk between
neoplastic and immune cells has moved
immunotherapy from phenomenology into
predictable and dependable standard of
care medicine this is not just another
cancer drug this is an entire industry
of treatment it really goes to the heart
of personalized medicine and is now
representing personalized therapy I will
talk about both the good points and the
bad points of the technology this is
going to change the way that we treat
oncology forever so here's my
for today I'm going to cover the history
and the background of the
immunotherapies they've been a long time
in coming and not all of them are
success stories we're going to review
the categories of immunotherapies I'll
talk about the mechanism of action or
what we think is the mechanism of action
I'll also cover the major biomarkers of
the eyeties I'll also talk about the
progress in clinical testing and I'll
touch upon the the adverse reactions of
some of the I t's along with some of the
the success stories
as way about
as I indicated in my introduction
research and the immunotherapies is
nothing new people have believed for
some time that they could stimulate the
immune system with nonspecific agents
so-called immuno stimulants these were
the most part has consisted of bacterial
toxins and cell components yet has met
with limited success but this actually
led to the next generation of
recombinant cytokines like interleukin 2
and alphasphere on some of these
cytokines are still used today
monoclonal have always been a staple of
immunotherapy but identifying cancer
targets that were unique to cancer cells
has been an issue monoclonal antibodies
have been used in cancer treatment for
over 25 years the poster child of course
is try to zoom ad or Herceptin which
dates back to the early 1990s
prophylactic vaccines have also been
around for decades but now with the
combination of immunotherapies they're
poised for a resurgence and last but not
least are the immune checkpoint
inhibitors that have been shown the most
promise today these include if a with a
map or hippie for short primrose map or
primrose novella map or knee though
these are three of many of the
immunotherapies there are lots of others
but I'm going to cover the big three
right now and I'll cover these as we go
along
so in the slide I just wanted to list
the four types of immunotherapies
currently available they are nonspecific
immune stimulation adoptive cell
transfer these also include tools as
well as car keys cell therapies
vaccination strategies as well as the
immuno checkpoint inhibitors I wanted to
emphasize again that I'm going to be
talking the majority of today about the
indian checkpoint blockade inhibitors
and i also wanted to add that these
therapies are not mutually exclusive
they can be used in communication with
other immunotherapies or conventional
treatments to get give even better
results
now this is an idealized a kaplan-meier
curve adopted from Joan Allison's
plenary talk a couple of years ago from
the ASCO meeting in immunology or I
should say in in oncology we're
accustomed to measuring a control curve
as outlined in purple this is usually
without drugs or treatment and we
measure that against a standard
therapies outlined in blue and we
measure the dish the difference so
that's the the black arrow in between
and here we're plotting the percent
survival versus time so you want as many
people to live as long as possible so
what we're looking for is a shift to the
right now the bigger the gap in between
the two curves the better along with the
immunotherapy is like if a lip map shown
in green we actually saw a great
response but more importantly we saw
durable responses at several years this
was remarkable this was the first time
in cancer treatments that this has been
noted and when they gave combination
therapies shown in red say nivo plus
hippy you even got better results
so remember that immunotherapy relies on
the presence of antigens on the cell
surface to stimulate t-cells this is the
iconic graph from Mike Lawrence and
Gaddy guesses nature paper in 2013 that
depicts the mutational burden of cancers
in the 27 cancers of the TCGA the cancer
genomic catalyst moving from left to
right you go from the childhood cancers
with smaller somatic mutation rates and
they give give way to adult cancers with
the larger mutational burdens these
cancers over on the right like melanoma
and lung cancer are products of
environmental exposure to carcinogens
like nicotine and UV light you can see
down at the bottom the circles plot that
go from a normal a circle without
connections or rearrangements on the
inside to more and more chromosomal
aberrations in indicating increased
genomic complexity and pathology
[Applause]
when you have either a cancer cell or a
vaccine they're producing and displaying
foreign antigens these antigens can be
on the cell surface or they can be in
solution antigens are things that your
immune system recognizes and mount an
immune response to this can be either
humoral or cellular a PCS or antigen
presenting cells will eat or phagocytize
these molecules and display them as
foreign antigens on the cell surface and
what they do is they actually educate
the t-cells to kill the tumor this
interaction is done the TCR or the
t-cell receptor these foreign particles
are what your t-cell responds to now the
t-cells are the most important cells
convenien response then you have a
cancer you'll start activating your T
cells that mobilize your immune system
these T cells will actually tell another
set of T cells to go out and proliferate
and start dividing they recognize the
tumor cells and it should kill them
that is what normally happens and it
probably does happen for the most part
you get a small tumor or a small
neoplastic event and the immune system
will clear you only know notice when the
system failed and you get a pronounced
tumor
the immune system then will up regulate
actually a particular protein on those
lymphocytes those killer lymphocytes
called PD 1 PD standing for program cell
death
now tumor cells are really clever and
they've figured out a way to get around
this so the cancer will get the kill
signal of the T cell and they get around
it by making a ligand called PD l1 so
the PDL one Ligon is displayed on the
cell surface of the tumor cell the PDL
one binds to the PD one and turns off
the kill signal of the lymphocytes the
PDL one is really a don't attack signal
this puts the immune system at a loss
and opens things up for cancers to grow
and to evolve
now the therapy
come out recently that's very exciting
is to block the inhibition of the
t-cells
so one of the most powerful ways is to
do this is actually to use antibodies
that recognize PD one on t-cells so the
answer i pd-1 antibodies block pd one
from binding to PDL one this the
timbersaw has been left vulnerable and
these effector T cells can now go and
kill the tumors these PDL or the PD one
antibodies are very powerful in fact
there are several on the market and
there are more to come this slide lists
two of them nivo and prim bro now
they've been used in a variety of
different cancers including melanoma
kidney lung cancer and I believe that
the the number is up to fifteen
different cancers that they've shown
efficacy this is a very clever way to
open up cancer cells to get attacked by
your immune system now there's another
approach that can be used which is a
general immune boost and that is through
the ctla4 inhibition system we'll go
back to our original graphic of the
tumor shedding and presenting antigen
the t cell in this picture is in contact
with the APC the antigen presenting cell
and the T cell is generating stimulatory
and inhibitory signals as indicated by
the the green and the red arrows
normally the system is in balance
between stimulation and inhibitory
signals and what we're trying to do is
to push and poorly immune system in
certain direction now the inhibitory
pathway is ctla4 and involves a protein
which is displayed on the surface of
this particular cell so this is an
inhibitory signal that modulates the
response of the immune system to keep
that depressed a little bit so it
doesn't go completely out of control you
don't want your immune
system to overreact to generate any self
antibodies or a graft-versus-host
reaction now if we add antibody that is
specific for ctla4 on the receptor we
can actually remove the inhibition
inhibition of the t-cell and it then
will go do what it was supposed to do
all along and that is recruit other
cells that will eventually attack the
tumor zone so antibodies that recognize
ctla-4 inhibit this inhibitory system
the net result is a hyper immune or a
hyper active t-cell which is something
you really want with cancer if you've
got cancer you're better off having a
hyper immune system than a depressed one
so these antibodies again inhibit the
signal that is inhibitory but they're
doing it at a different point and on a
different cell type than the the PDO one
antibodies so the T cells get activated
and enhances the whole immune system
this is effective in some cancers but
not all and that's one of the mysteries
about immunotherapy is why it's working
in some cancers but not all cancers so
given with a map or opdivo from
bristol-myers Squibb is one of those
antibodies that's out there against
ctla4 now it's been used very
successfully in melanoma
is without a coupler of the biomarkers
on tumor cells and immune cells like
pd-1 PDL 1 and ctla-4 but what I didn't
tell you what it was that there were a
lot more biomarkers that people are
investigating these either up regulates
the killer cell population or down
regulate the inhibitory cells so
currently there are 24 inhibitory
molecules and 5 positive or stimulatory
molecules that people are looking at as
molecular targets obviously if you start
mixing drugs and targets there are a lot
of potential combinations to push and
pull the immune system to react against
cancer antigens all of these potential
targets are in different cell types and
eyevac grafted a few of these for you so
for example tissue macrophages that
process antigen the tumor cell itself
the regulatory and the effector cells
all of these have cellular cellular
receptors that can be regulated even
upregulated or downregulated to give the
desired immune response
and of course there is a lot of business
and a lot of financial interests in this
area because cancer drugs can make big
money here is a partial list of some of
the immunotherapy companies I'm sure
that there are more coming you'll notice
that they're both established pharma
companies like bristol-myers Squibb
Roche Merck Astra Zeneca that are on
there as well as a whole host of
different startup companies
now there are a number of cancer
immunotherapies and clinical trials here
I've actually broken it down into tissue
type the take-home message here is that
there are many different cell types that
are represented
so immunotherapy is against all cancers
are all a lot of different types of
cancers not just one particular ones
now here is a short list and I'm sure
it's going to get a lot longer of the
immuno or the union checkpoint
inhibitors that are approved or
currently in late-stage clinical trials
and probably will be approved within a
year or two you'll notice that all of
these are monoclonal antibodies as
indicated by the suffix of nab on the
generic name
now once one thing I'd like to point out
is how immunotherapies are quickly being
adopted into the standard of care
guidelines these are the new NCCN
guidelines released in March of this
year for colorectal cancer there is now
a provision for giving either nivo or
been broke for DMM are deficient
mismatch repair genes or for MSI high
that's microsatellite instability high
tumors so the take-home message here is
that immunotherapy is now being accepted
as part of the standards of care
now in a related story the FDA has
granted accelerated approval to print
bro for the first time as a tissue or a
site agnostic indication this occurred a
couple of months ago in May the
indications here are adult or pediatric
patients with unresectable or metastatic
cancer that is either MSI high or
deficient in mismatch repair genes so
all of those patients are eligible now
this particular indication is for solid
tumors that have progressed and that
this actually represents about 5% of
colorectal patients will present
probably with MSI high or deficient
mismatch repair genes again this is
remarkable because it is tissue or site
agnostic and the FDA has never done this
before
the second interesting thing about this
study is that the number of patients
that were used in the clinical trial was
only 149 so this is remarkably few
patients for the FDA to approve approve
a major drug so it really indicates that
the FDA is embracing immunotherapies and
it probably reflects their thinking that
the immunotherapies are lower risk than
the current chemo therapies and targeted
therapies so remember
all of these tests that I've just
mentioned reflect genomic instability
and complexity so if we go back to our
graph that map's the frequency of
somatic mutations per cancer we can
actually now overlay categories of tumor
burden as measured in the number of
mutations per megabase as you can see
some of the the tumors on the right-hand
side are yielding 10 to 100 mutations
per megabase that's a lot what this
really means is that you're generating
these neo antigens forming on the cell
surface so if you look at the graph or
the figure over on the left hand side we
actually have a tumor and if we sequence
it we can identify these mutations all
of these mutations are a certain portion
of these mutations will lead to changes
in the protein and some of these will
actually present themselves on the cell
surface these new surface proteins are
called neo antigens because the immune
system has not seen them before so the
neo antigens are thought to be the
target or the new target of the T cells
so only tumor expressing lots of neo
antigens should in theory respond better
to the immunotherapies the more
mutations in the tumor means more Neil
antigens which means a better response
to immunotherapies so TBM or tumor
mutational burden is emerging as a great
biomarker for immunotherapy
unfortunately there are no specific
rules or guidelines at this time for
this testing so people are still kind of
developing the rules around it
now the laboratory tests for of cancer
biomarkers can now be separated into two
classes one is genotypic testing and
this is based on the specific nucleotide
content these have these can have
specific genomic coordinates or can be
variable so examples of these are
classic b-raf the 600d variant or copy
number variants or any structural
variants in Dells gene expression which
measures of course RNA or any of the
rearrangements of fusions also mismatch
repair genes will fall into this the
other new type of of test is phenotypic
in nature in that it is not based on
specific genetic variance that is
measuring a phenotype or a function or a
characteristic of the cell so examples
of these include the MSI the
microsatellite instability or the tumour
mutational burden the TMB these are
characteristics of the tumor and not of
a specific gene
here's a table of the lab tests they can
be used to identify the possibility of
neo antigens on the cell surface and
hints would make good candidates for
immunotherapy if they're positive unless
our testing has been around for many
years and has been used for testing of
Lynch syndrome and the susceptibility of
inherited colon cancer it is a PCR test
it's very very simple it takes about
five or so mono or polymorphic repeat
markers a PCR those up and then venom
out on a gel and analyze first ability
of that region it can also be the you
can also do that that same test instead
of a sizing gel you could run it out on
a sequencer and measure the the fragment
length i just told about the tumor
burden TNB so I'm going to skip over
that but I I will say that a number of
different labs are using it are doing it
today and they're usually using large
comprehensive NGSS to make that
available deficient miss mismatch repair
genes they're looking for either a
germline or a somatic mutation and the
certain gene FM gene families associated
with mismatch repair
again it is a characteristic of
hereditary colorectal cancer remember
that MSI and the DMM are mutations can
either be germline or somatic now
in the personalized medicine space or
the personalized cancer vaccine space is
the vaccination strategy now the goal
here is to identify neo antigens or
peptides that are unique to the tumor so
this starts with patient with a German
the tumor is surgically removed or
biopsied the sample is then made into an
NGS library in sequence
ideally you would be able to sequence
the entire genome but there are several
groups and companies that are doing this
with just sequencing the genome or the
exome or a subset of cancer genes now
the results are from the sequencing are
compiled and run through algorithms that
will actually predict the abundance and
the antigenicity of the predicted
proteins and if they are expressed on
the cell surface so you can actually go
one of two ways
one is to determine if if you want to
give the patient standard generic
immunotherapy or if you actually want to
go a more holistic way and that is to
personalize by synthesizing peptides
that are predicted to be the most
antigenic immuno genic
and then either incubate these with
immune cells through adoptive cell
transfer from the patient or directly
inject the peptides to into the patient
so again there are many options with
regrets you know therapy and again they
can you can do these in combination or
you can do them in combination with
conventional treatment hopefully the
treatment will educate the patient's own
immune system to respond to the tumor
cell without attacking the normal cells
this is truly personalized medicine and
a very clever way to fight cancer
so those are all
mostly the good things about
immunotherapy I did want to just have a
slight or two on some of the bad side of
immunotherapy there are some side
effects or common adverse events in
treating patients with immunotherapy
this graph shows it the Crimbo prim bro
and neither and also if he plus plus an
Evo combination and it met the these
treatments to diarrhea fatigue nausea
varieties and skin rashes now the drug
makers are very much aware of these side
effects and they're paying close
attention to any possibility of adverse
reactions during therapy or during
clinical trials and they're monitoring
these patients very closely another a
bad side
you know therapy is the prices
unfortunately this is not positive the
cost of immunotherapies is very very
high
here's an example of knee though and
it'd be treatment alone being well over
a hundred thousand dollars and the
combination of therapies being nearly
three hundred thousand and I also should
add that the this price is per year this
actually brings up an interesting point
and that is we're still not quite sure
how to administer these drugs so some
people some of the the treatments have
done one administration two
administrations three administrations
that's kind of arbitrary and there is
research that's going on to sort this
out but it could turn out that you only
need one dose of these very powerful
drugs to essentially turn on your immune
system to educate it and then you don't
need anymore
so that could be one of the the good
sides of immunotherapy
more important features of the
immunotherapies and how they differ from
existing therapies is that they can and
they are being used in combination with
the other conventional or
immunotherapies the conventional
therapies of course being radiation
therapy chemotherapy and the targeted
therapies so together with all the other
sorts of treatment you can induce your
immune system to attack cancer and at
the same time be using the traditional
target of treatments either drugs or
radiation so it's really a one-two punch
obviously the number of combinations and
different you know therapies and
conventional therapies is very large and
of course everybody will react
differently so it's going to be
interesting to watch to see how the
clinical testing of combinatorial
therapies is done to get enough patients
to actually prove that it is efficient
you
so I just wanted to end with
prominent success story or at least so
far it's a success story and that is
President Jimmy Carter he was diagnosed
with melanoma and it spread to his liver
and his brain he underwent surgery
radiation therapy and of course that did
this new kind of cancer treatment
immunotherapy he underwent remission and
it seems to be
I shouldn't say cured but they cannot
detect any of the cancer in today Jimmy
Carter was given Prem brow which is an
anti PDL one antibody from work it's
going to be interesting to see how
durable President Carter's remission
really is but for right now he seems to
be disease-free so some
is a very exciting area and there is a
lot of hope as well as hype your immune
system can be used to fight cancer even
the most aggressive kinds and in fact
they work the best for immunotherapy
cancer has figured out a way to block
the immune response using PDL one
ligands in many kinds of cancers one
strategy is to make therapeutics that
block the PDL one inhibitory pathway
antibodies from people are being used
with the anti PD one antibodies they are
binding to the t-cell and releasing it
from inhibition case or cancer vaccines
can be used broadly on a number of
people with common antigens and for
those people if it works that's great
but there's another backup therapy and
that is to actually personalize the
treatment with peptides so that you
boost the individuals in the in response
again this is truly personalized
diagnosis analysis as treatment this is
really the way that cancer therapy
should be
and what I'd like
do is show you my references that made
this talk possible there are some really
great websites to learn more about
immunotherapies my favorite is shown on
this slide it is Susie or the Society
for immunotherapy of cancer and you can
go to this website and learn more they
actually have different different areas
depending on if you're a doctor a
researcher or a patient there's some
great patient information there there's
also a new textbook which has just been
published and you can get again more
information at the sixe site so with
that I'd like to say thank you very much
to the audience for tuning in and I'd
like to turn it back to Julie thank you
dr. Carmack for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started our first question is how are CA
RT cells involved in immunotherapy yeah
so that's a very good question so I
didn't have a lot of time to go into the
the car t-cells story there one of the
the promising areas of research coming
along very strongly so Claire actually
stands for chimeric antigen receptor
these are genetically engineered cells
to attack cancer what one-car t-cell
therapy is expected to be approved this
year for the treatment of children with
acute lymphoblastic leukemia or äôll a
second for adults with advanced lymphoma
is probably also going to be approved
either this year or early next year it's
it's still early for car T cells and
other adaptive cell transfer methods
they're not quite as advanced as the
immuno blockades methods are that
they're certainly showing a lot of
promise one question that people have
been kind of asking is do I use the
checkpoint blockade inhibitors for solid
cancerous solid tumors and the adoptive
cell transfer methods for hematological
disorders or can they can you mix and
match them essentially are both
the the methodologies used against
everything and to tell you the truth we
don't know the answer that we're not
quite sure what the sweet spot for each
of the technologies is
thank you the next question is which
companies do tumor mutational burden
testing yeah I believe a foundation
medicine was actually the first report
on the team can be the tumor of
mutational burden with foundation one
and then they they came out with
foundation team tests so they actually
actually report those can be as well as
the MSI the microsatellite status I know
that there are other large comprehensive
tests like in SK impact that are also
reporting this
there was a nature medicine paper from
the group the MSI or the M SK group a
couple of months ago that showed this I
think anybody can do this type of test
with enough sequencing capacity and I
believe that there are some algorithms
in the public domain to help calculate
this
thank you how is Timur mutational burden
reported yeah so the TMP is recorded as
the number of mutations in a specific
area of genetic content so it could be
reported in a couple of different ways
like mutations in a Cell mutations in a
tumor most commonly I think it's it's
done as mutations per megabase or areas
the genome equal to the length of a mega
base so they if they don't have a mega
bit so sequence they may actually
extrapolate it to give that number again
this is probably the most common way of
doing it how they how they make their
their cut-offs I'm not quite sure you
know how that if you know ten mutations
per megabase is enough or 20 or 30 or or
where the cutoff is to be considered
high or moderate or low and that I'm not
sure and I think that's actually up to
the individual company so remember that
that all of the company's labs are
coming up with their own definitions of
some of these these terms and depending
on their design and their technology
these there's not a consensus way as
measuring it yet
thank you we'll wrap up with one more
question and that question is what is
the difference between nivo and prim bro
yeah so they're they're not the same
drug
they're both monoclonal antibodies that
recognize pd-1 but they were generated
independently of one another Pro is made
by merck and levi was made by
bristol-myers Squibb they're both whole
antibodies but prim brow is humanized
from a mouse antibody and then grafted
onto a human back though while neither
was made from transgenic mice with
transplanted human immunoglobulin genes
then you inject the mouse and then you
make a monoclonal antibody they they're
actually different molecular weights and
I think that actually reflects that
they're probably different classes of
heavy chains they're both campus I would
guess that they're they're probably both
IgG cores
I would like to once again thank dr.
Carnac for his presentation do you have
any final comments now I just like to
say thank you very much for attending
and this is a very exciting field and to
watch this area because there's going to
be a lot more developments in
immunotherapies
thank you once again dr. Carmack I would
also like to thank lab roots and Vela
Diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 14th
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye